I take responsibility for all of the
policies of my government that we are
doing what we can to mitigate truly
austerity but the way to end to the
austerity is to do at source and you
know if you look at its interests if you
look at the labor UK manifesto all of
the policies the Jeremy Corbyn is
putting forward from Scotland tuition
fees to scrapping hospital car parking
charges to climate change these are all
policies already implemented it's
interesting you say that is leading the
we ensure near Corbin and having some
similar policies to you would you prefer
to see him as UK Prime Minister westerly
to make I want to see a strong voice for
Scotland in the House of Commons sort my
job the questions I ask you directly
ug preferred CJ I'm hoping auto-resize
because that's not going to be idle ways
no matter how they do I don't want to
see 20 governments of 20 Prime
Minister's that they do real damage to
Scotland I think one of the things Libre
has got an answer for in this election
is that we've put forward and a leader
lacks credibility in terms of people's
perception of his ability to be Prime
Minister so all of that means if you
want Scotland to have the strongest
voice then vote SNP to make sure we get
that Tory MPs will be rubber stamps for
what to visa me at want to do whatever
that is from an extreme breaks it
through to further austerity and the
risk in Scotland of rooting labour is
that you let the Tories in instead so if
you want Scotland's interest to be
protected and the strongest possible
voice for Scotland with the big
challenges we face over the next few
years then the only way to get that and
Scotland to support SNP